hey guys welcome to The Rubin Report
I'm Dave Rubin, we have a great show for ya, Gina grad
Vanessa Barnett with us and let's get
right to it
Hillary Clinton she was interviewed by
those fine people over at Fox News ooo
scary right she sat in between
greta van susteren on one side
Brett Baer any other she got pretty
severe whiplash from the question of
course
literally happened there was about Ben
guys he had heard there some kinda
situation the republicans are all gone
crazy about
let's take a look my own assessment
careened from
you know the video had something to do
with that the video had nothing to do
with it may have affected some people it
didn't affect
other people and I think the the
conclusion to draw
because we were not just monitoring what
was happening and Ben Ghazi
wanted began to unfold but remember we
had a very dangerous
assault honor embassy in Cairo that same
day
which was clearly linked to that video
so I was trying to make sense of it
and you know I think that be
investigations that have been carried
out
basically conclude we can't say that
everybody was influencing we can say
everybody wasn't
but what the intelligence community said
was spontaneous protests and that is
what
at the time they thought okay so
actually she did what lot politicians
issue really say anything we start a new
week I didn't know I we did the best we
could but I actually
pretty much think that's the truth I
don't think they intentionally try to
get these people killed like
and I think they probably did the best
they could to secure our embassy in our
people their
arms without getting into the
nitty-gritty a ban gai Zhi which no one
seems to know the truth
about with a do questions like this on
Fox News
a what's the goal is to go to just keep
hitting the bases go to change any did
like
to she thinks she's changing anyone's
mind with an answer like that this box
think they're change I did load
like the bigger sorta media question
about it well first can I just say the
girl looks good in royal blue
they recall that recall rate choice for
her better waiting I'm a real democrat
artillery jewel tone read by the way
danger 0
own yeah thank you I
a fair question because when you're
invited onto a show
present company excluded I think the
point is to either
you know pay you know corner make you
look stupid or get you to say something
completely outrageous that you never
want to say
I think her whole job which I think she
did a great job that
was just taking the fuel on the fire
quelling if it issued a little double
talking with super vague
I think she did what she was supposed to
do right so is that their purpose they
bring her on there they know she's not
gonna say anything and that's pretty
much what she did we sorta knew we
didn't know about a lot but
it's a fair question you're going to ask
in the they want the kinda pope the bear
little bit India
what her reaction I think they honestly
do want something that they can
you know put on a headline sooo look at
hillary seeded this and they might even
try to spend something that she did say
but like you said she played it safe and
it was
babe I think a lot of times in politics
you have to keep in Vegas when you say
something
and you kind of have to go back on that
all my got the wall come with yeah
crashing down on me a bad having to tell
the truth and say what you actually
believe people would
people would freak out and this isn't
just some random woman I mean this is
somebody who's going to be
running for president presumably the 30
whose band obviously super connected to
the Obama White House because she works
for an
so what I think expected today right so
the so that I think do you think this is
more about them attacking
Obama or attacking her this their
preemption on 26 feel like we gotta keep
this thing going we know Obama
out no matter what so forget it let's
just keep the pressure on her why not
double down
I mean if they are it doesn't matter it
either if they're trying to get
get Obama presently or get her for the
future they win either way
yeah a rental him up I mean it's what's
this I don't be a wimp the private kinda
like their MO that's what they did
so speaking of the remote so let's get
away from a guy the I think that's the
interesting thing here is that everyone
was framing this as hillary's going up
box news it's so scary
but in a weird way isn't that a
condemnation in that no defensive Fox
News
but is there a condemnation of the rest
of our media because the implication is
well there is a media loves their
big ever softball questions all the time
but now she's going up odd to me that
it's really scary
and actually be watched the interview I
still think wasn't that scary there was
nothing particularly
a you know pointing yeah it was pretty
tame so isn't it a bigger condemnation
of the media
that we thought we have one help with
that supposed to be the scary one for
democrats
I think this historically they have been
the assholes up to me
yeah I mean that's what they know they
kinda set themselves up that way so that
now we're just thought cousins they all
of newsletters blogs that we watch it
it's pretty tame
but we're still gonna be like daughter
she's gonna five loses
just the history and what they've done
yeah they don't that will for themselves
so it's not like we're all
pouncing on them for no reason great if
you wanna be sent a shot beat with a
shot but don't be mad when people assume
that's what you're gonna do again
and I will say I don't think the rest
the media gives a soft ball questions I
think they
they asked the pertinent questions but
they're not coming from a vicious
malicious
angle and I think in the past maybe not
with this interview but in fact that the
process
yes so we've got a budget stories on her
and I absolutely can't
supporter I just don't think we need
political dynasties her husband was
president
I think knowing my family's been
president I think if you someone in your
family the president's are you don't get
to be president but I got
I don't have car UN concert tickets if
you're that he really works for love
where you live
yeah run yeah
but see it look at it now great now I'm
really right now
good I I'm so I so I'm just completely
get there because I just do I just think
we need fresh new people this is just me
more the same
where you george bush had a son do it
like I just don't think already people
are saying that the
Michelle Obama might run for Senate inge
Illinois
let's just admit it and with gotta let
go by quick but for
yeah exactly I think everybody yeah well
so why bother is as women because you
are women so they must represent all
women that our
rather women do you are you more
inclined
to vote for her
I'm gonna be honest yes yeah and I'm I'm
I didn't vote for Obama
just because he was black but hey I'm
not gonna lie that was a part of it is
like you want that as after I won t you
want that the woman I want to see our
in the white house and I know what we
say about you know the same ol rigmarole
but you also want someone you can trust
and so because she's been and AM because
I love claim that the president
I'm more inclined to say okay she's a
woman she understands that
and she knowles the game she knows these
people as I just trust their little bit
more I don't want some guy I've never
heard of before
come in and my ball save the day I don't
think that's what I hear you and in a
weird way I would be more inclined to
vote for bill again so I guess that take
a little
what better way to monitor before what
you think that would push you a little
bit
honestly I I don't know why
like if I'm saying this because I'm
exhausted not for our sleep because I
cap situation those dealing with or
because they really believe I don't know
but at this moment I really feel like
that stuff can't matter can't matter if
she's a woman it can't matter
it it just can't yeah though I am NOT
I don't wanna just completely counter
out the like
wilbur because and I had she would be
part of this dynasty and i cant say will
it doesn't matter what she stands for I
wanna supporter because she's one and I
just
I maybe there's a party that does feel
that way I don't know I don't think so
though I just
I can't have those be the reason yeah
iraq is a total freak en masse you
probably have heard about that
a so right now I sis which is the
islamic
they in Iraq and Syria or I feel as
present about us going
the Islamic state in Iraq and the Lovat
is basically marching through Iraq
they'd split the country pretty much
into three
territories are based on you know
sectarian stop in the Sunni and Shia and
all that stuff
okay I want to get to too deep into a
cover-up policy wonks here
a but a present Obama said that he was
going to send any troops without that
275 troops to secure our embassy which
people are no
the Embassy in Baghdad is the biggest US
Embassy in the world there are 5,000
US citizens that work there I there may
be limited drone strikes
it's all good fun unfolding very quickly
so again we are not experts in security
but that's why I'm doing the show to
have sort of normal people talk about
the broader issues
arm what we do saw the course right now
about a big way no pressure I was just
cuz they bring in Archer
if any Dr Archer fans blow but though
that I sis figure that a knife is
Rafferty I
dole I I don't know I don't know what to
do and I
it doesn't matter if you're listening to
a.m. talk at the top
everybody's talking about this and
nobody knows what to do
yeah so if they don't know and they get
paid to figure it out I shares yet we
are you saying that we shouldn't be
listening to the same people the
architect to the original Iraq war right
now because all those guys they're all
showing up all over the place
where that time so yeah
why is it that when they put these
people back on the cable news channels
they don't put under their names
bucked up the person yeah lawyering
bought fell 6.2 expert know it right
expert
exactly yeah a so really what
the what do you think we should let me
look it's a freakin this is a disaster
this could cause
this could cause I Jordan to fall also I
mean this is just the beginning
275 troops obviously maybe can defend
our embassy but can't defend a country
and does it even matter should we get
let the mall kill each other do we
exactly do we it that are
role too take care I don't think so I
don't know I was trying to read through
all the facts and I can just us just so
happy
but I do agree that we need the troops
there to protect
our people and that's why we think four
as hard as you want to save a
because he said no truth in any at the
San Fermin edited by Hemanta back on
your work but
at the end of the day I think their goal
is the goal that we should all be
worried about
protecting are people that are there
everything out I just kinda wanna stay
outta
yes it'll only come back on us and then
we ran another war
so I i basically agree with you like
there's nothing we can do these
these people hated each other forever
this goes beyond us but
we did throw a bomb literally when we
went to war there
so should we to you you are with guilt
the
your image you are guilty conscience
lead us back into cleaning up
anything as if we even if it was
remotely possible that we could order
today
that go place now the leaders are we
screwed up sorry
and that they are me I don't mean to
oversimplify but that the fact that I do
it's lonely at the top
you know when when we do go in were
bullies when we don't go in that were
heartless
yeah so I don't know what what makes
this situation different every other
situation
that that we've Ben struggling with
grief
to try to fix it or do we stay out of it
because either way we're gonna be in
trouble
yeah what you make it a good others i'ma
make it worse Yahoo that we're gonna fix
it might give
even a week then everyone and there's no
guarantee that will fix it it's probably
going to far worse yet what would you
guys make the general
beam in the country with C which seems
to be that we should be pulling back
from the rest of the world you know to
me like that everything happened
in Ukraine ready to talk about you can
anymore we we've sorta lost in terms of
what we said
what was supposed to happen in russia
we're pretty much 10 K
what would you think that is the general
feeling in the united states like that
we sorta don't have a role
anymore which is sorta what Obama
promised the he said we're going to step
back
brand and that's what happened when I
promise down yeah he had we want the
promise even there's a lot of bad shit
happened right
I think you just get to a point where
you're fed up and like just like we're
talking right now over well we don't
think we can fix anything
why why put ourselves in a position to
make it far worse for them
Enfora it's like let's just wash our
hands step away and
readership our focus for this thing
there we need to work on
yeah and I don't think we want to use
our resources for outside
outside problems right is there anyone
that you should watch on TV on any other
news channels that you really trust when
it comes to this is there any politician
that when they come on you feel like
they really know what they're talking
about or have you think scandal
they're all I gotta watch me good how's
the card that had a pretty good said
we're going to do it their all I
right i mean is there any way that you
watch that you like this guy really has
ironically job i din when he was running
for president in 2008 before he joined
Obama
he was the one saying that there's this
country needs to be split into three
things Bay
which is crazy could ever think the guys
completely not now but I'll young girl
Joe
crazy crazy are going he was making this
point way back that never really is
there anyone that you
well then you can I say I do then I end
up looking like an idiot
because it's because they they there so
let me know below their so charming and
they're just there folksy I like that
but it doesn't end up mattering I don't
know what they know what they
I only know what they want you to know
so I always end up feeling stupid anyway
I greater but alright from Iraq
let's move back here to america although
this is a worldwide company too if I am
not mistaken mcdonald's people are not
happy with them and their
score I the American Customer Service
index is
balling all let's take a look
so this is a favorability score for
pretty big chain restaurants fast food
restaurant we do a budget passed would
step here
people people are always very passionate
about it so
papillons doing pretty well they got a
82 at a hundred which is the
been moved from last year people like
them in 2013 they like I'm in 2014
Pizza Hut number too so people seem to
really like
no generic chain heated is that where
you guys fauna
year old from the midwest I didn't know
if there was anything more exotic than a
pizza hut but
backed away from their I don't know how
you could diamond right so this is like
new york obviously you're not gonna go
to Pizza Hut or dominos or Papa Johns
young got real peace but I let that go
back to start their again then Little
Caesars a Domino's Pizza the first four
people are very satisfied
which she Peter I but then okay so
they're on the bottom
are the last four Burger King Dunkin
Donuts KFC
talk about McDonagh again defied their
so mcdonald's really kinda struggling
and I was when I was watching something
in
you know that people have said that
their numbers their their take on right
now is dropping
a little bit companies is partly just
people like to beat up
on the thing that they secretly love
like everyone talks shit about Walmart
and everyone shops there
you know although I actually I went
there to get a big screen TV in the
customer service was so bad actually
brought the TV
up carry the TV myself brought it to the
razor and was taking so long and they're
being so unpleasant I just left it there
yeah jury finds you return the sport
coat despite Perak
I got yeah I'll I
nearly burst but yeah we're really
getting that summer what's going on here
like without hasn't changed that much
there's no reason you know I'll yeah all
alive
it we're all alive in the world I'll be
by mcdonald's because is both a bit like
element I'll
got and then you go and you buy the
entire dollar menu
new roomier let me ask McDonald you
can't say that like
be at this is in this day and age for
everyone be organic and natural and
gluten-free an XY and z.
you can't say like how do you feel after
you've done that in your room
just portal dollar and forget that yeah
I question spiral I could change my
earlier too
we should all go out without you getting
correctly I don't you
whatever it is this like secret hate
like you ok well I haven't got the email
absolutely disagree for one reason yeah
because I don't know if it was two days
ago or yesterday
the the me abominable horrible thing
that happened to that little girl at KFC
when
she was mauled by a dog yeah and she was
scarred and the family took great care
of the
asked her to leave a little girl because
making the other customers I'm
comfortable
if that's what customer service is a
fast food bahcall about the and that is
what our customers after their not
already quite served to fall
by the way I'm pretty sure kFC has now
helped her pay some medical book
show understand the corporate wasn't
there there's just some dude
drug whatever I don't hurt the
thousand-dollar for
medical bills or million that a lawsuit
yeah I am
you don't blame the founder of it on
right occur or that
cracking but I do understand you know if
they probably wouldn't have wanted their
employees that treat another person like
that
but if that's the culture your breeding
then I don't feel sorry for you and
there is a lot to that because here even
in LA now that I wanna make everything
out early but if you were to go to In N
Out
in a smile there friendly I mean Erica
point-of-service look me in the eye
they are happy to be there but now they
don't give a flying fuck about you when
I get to take their pay and everything
is different business model at
but a good but OK KFC because the other
two so at the bottom
were KFC and Taco Bell Taco Bell I think
has the reverse thing a mic is it cool
to like Taco Bell
you it's for breathing everywhere
for you under they got the Dorito is a
to keep the kids love it there at some
Taco Bell playing that the back
commercial for the old people in every
bank kidwell
so I think they get the reversing
somehow it's cool to say
that you like talk about not cool to say
you like made out to my and I think I'm
well
completely is the same thing as movie
idiocracy they may reach
got you can take the remaining nine
ingredients and shuffle the deck in a
different way
get all the product to get people
excited they're geniuses were morons but
their G
by the way in the movie idiocracy which
is such an underrated Matt really so
spectacular the one
fast food restaurant that survives the
future is Carl's junior which didn't
which is horrible
which is horrible that didn't even make
a the press
people like you good players not on the
list that cover the
always like that happen question what
about the gay bareback gay them
up are I okay but
people though fight
you know what we had Paris area on a
couple months ago and he made the same
are you and I love their idea I want gay
people like what
you know you can't wait you can't win
over him I anyway the point is made out
with just not that great
at you probably be happier elsewhere
okay
the better with another channel it talk
about Starbucks they're actually doing
something that's pretty cool
they've announced that they're going to
be paying for
tuition for two years online classes at
Arizona State University for
some other employees we've got more info
about seventy percent of Starbucks a
hundred thirty-five thousand US
employees have not completed
undergraduate degrees
employees can now choose any more than
40 undergraduate degrees in art limited
to only business classes so you can do
whatever you want which is cool because
a lot of people working at Starbucks
are doing it so they can become artists
or whatever they whatever they want to
be
employees are required to stay with the
company after receiving their degrees
and tuition is approximately
30,000 for two years to bill I mean
Israel they're the real investment that
they're making
with their place understanding that
these people are not always going to be
with them and they're gonna go to fill
their own dreams
a pretty great right at of them up to
get a job at Starbucks
yeah but it's fantastic because a lot of
times you didn't stop and there's wanna
hold you there they don't want to grow
they want to stay in your position so
they can make money
of love you this is like the complete
reverse their giving you money and
giving you wings lead to fly into
something else yeah
expect so isn't that the real beauty in
this whole operation it's totally
counterintuitive do business model to
get you to a place for you don't have to
work at that company anymore
and I'm suspicious ok with I can smell
I don't know what I don't even know what
a special but I'm not suspicious because
this is
it seems too good to be true they don't
care what you major and
they'll pay for it they don't care if
you start a
if you work at Starbucks continue all my
classes and quit
they don't really care as long as you're
working what twenty hours a week
its to good I'm afraid they're gonna
catch by how much does this kind of that
make you want to go
to Starbucks so when you hear that they
give all their employees health
insurance you know before Obamacare
whatever
did that affect even if their coffee
isn't the greatest like to think very
good but Matthew
I don't even care if they burn their
beans I so excited that they're doing
there I think I've
really and truly people threat the
American history you join the military
to get a benefit like that
yeah and this is just you know make a
couple double lot they've got like 200
dealing with people in the morning
before they had a coffee can be quite
like a war
you know proprietary your eyes sure I
just think this is so
phenomenon I just hope that world not
being duped because it's so good it's
it's just so good at them yeah how much
in this comes the thing from like
just a business perspective just people
talking about like we're talking about
and they get that good
that goodwill verses like sorta but real
genuine caring
for their employees may not matter which
actually yeah I think
we all to corporations that a person
right
what about a five dollar lot today but
if you're not telling me
all a dollar here five dollars goes the
help young men in here
achieve her goal being a neuroscientist
cardiac yeah
about my coffee cucumber neuroscientist
at
online at Arizona State University that
might not make it was she gathered her I
don't make this about that
me to grab your life have you heard the
new terms
bordeaux sexual yes porno sexual
are the new metro sexual a Mark Simpson
who the journalist who coined
the term extra sexual and the Israeli
guy that started private 10 years ago
cared what they look like
they wore clothes that were a little
tighter have a little gayer but they
were gay they were straight guy that
thing to look we'll get there
put your poll more product in their back
anything I kept feeling good about my
hair
belgrade I but now
he's now talking about bordeaux sexual
than this is this new
group man who works who are hyper sexual
and body obsessed we got an explanation
be
spore no sexual with their painstakingly
pumped and chisel body's muscle
enhancing tattoos piercings
adorable beards and plunging neckline
did eye-catching we clear that the
second generation
Metro sexuality is less about close that
it was for the first
their own bodies more than clobber and
product had become the ultimate
accessories
fashioning them at the jam into a hot
commodity one that they share and
compare
in an online marketplace so the online
marketplace that you talk about a corset
social media that people are
taken the you know LP's everywhere at
the gym perfect body tattoo
and tight haircut Bala I am
is this the is the gay agenda
is it work with are tinkering all the
straight people gay is that happening
here get yeah
children but yeah fantastic I'm I think
the first ball
it's a great definition terrible name
yet don't like you have some sort of
that
spore induced STD yeah but God bless
Sport au secteur the first thing I
thought I mean you know my gold
investing
darkness more neck so I thought it was
someone that says
with BR there perhaps which it might be
a good idea to your
can't live in a world that wonderful
there is no utopia were everywhere
esparto thank you everyone up that biti
but I think this is absolutely accurate
is that bad i mean
hit the word hipsters so played out I
don't even think that definition early
means anything anymore
I think it's the sport is actually got
barely got the poll lunging neckline
yeah
and you have all your glamour muscles
exactly where you want them
you probably can actually lift something
heavy but you've got great right
so much and this is what your it right
right well this reminds me of my little
with value it at all these guys that
have huge muscles and they probably
couldn't throw a ball
four feet away exacted some things we
could do about the visual
quite do you do you like these kinda guy
I love it I'm rather than if
used to not wear clothes anymore yeah
wants to wear clothes but I have
James Franco to wholeness jogging at the
europeans on Instagram
I thought something that the day where
now you know you will speed up new
firmware 3.0
not that might one find something up
this is like a ball
hit like fat yet to the lower one flat
because no one worked well
the wonders of the absent arms in the
Nepal their whatever for you
I didn't think on the neck could go down
to your ankle right led what is the
National Parole blood what is it love it
yeah well do you think there's some
element bit
that men lose a little something
something that women love about men and
maybe that when they're
so into themselves numero is complaining
every second every is about the man
complaining the white
care about what your hair battle ahead
now matter doing it now and then
the other key players why why did God it
takes longer to get ready tonight right
and I mean that for me that's impossible
because I mean clearly this took no more
talented
fine with that that's how comfortable
but I think that
I think there that you're both ready
it's fun i can't. it's fun to look at
fun to make fun of it fun to talk about
it's fun to see pictures I love
but in general do I feel like I'm gonna
connect
somebody who is just like all oiled up
probably not like I
but I love the conversation yeah what
would you think what the face after this
if it started you had regular guys that
you had the metro sexual now we got this
morn a sec I'm easy its just
everyone's important that that well that
that we might 30 done that what are both
about something that you gave us a
rolled into bed
those growth for roadway you have to
write I think
what it does is it breeds more narcissus
about and
Instagram the self be the us either
everything is the
it didn't breen I it's all about me
me look at my have this is over the top
is over the top
be a a new stereo Japan is saying that
people who stare at screens all day long
laptop screens specifically
phone screen they are actually changing
the liquid
in their eyes this is really deranged
they're changing tear fluid
the similar to people who have a disease
known as dry eye
but look at some info on them the
protein
and youth c5a see what might be the
protein secreted by cells in the upper
eyelid makes up part of the normally
occurring mucus layer or tear film the
key to the I voiced we all have this
that's why you can blink
and it keeps bad Dustin being that your
eyes study participants with the most
screen time
had MU c5a sea levels nearing those are
people
with diagnose dry eye so when I was
reading this
a literally I had just woke up
and do you guys go to your phones right
when you wake up because I do it
it's a bad habit I've been trying to
break it and I look at my phone
and there are times especially first
thing in the morning I wake up and my
eyes are dry
and I'm literally I got one eye and I
lower the light on the iPhone yet
I'm going like this like wanted so
this is happening this is real
what do you think I how do you keep your
eyes moist
well I know the first thing about others
can be so many people are going
this is do with it be at the not true
shut up
but those are people who don't want to
accept that the things that they're
doing
are bad for them yeah so it I think it's
it's probably true I'm willing to
up go for it maybe put my phone down for
another half hour before we go
do you have that you do you have any
moments where you realize that your eyes
a bother you cuz the screen at the new
thing now is everyone's making their
screens darker at night
somehow I don't actually yeah I'm but
we know this is real because one other
guy in China recently that the taxes
retroactive effect thing I wouldn't
girlfriend literally yet
they're gonna pop of neck any feel like
was insane at work
were rooting are tear ducts were our
eyeballs are popping out over scolding
me
maybe we put the phone down for five
minutes yeah I mean our are you doing
this are you walking around with a power
increasing also directly on this all day
long
although I I'm walked into two glass
like
my lovely I nowhere and downed it done
but when I read I if out the little
incentive program like
do I like diagnosed drivers so many
other things that are so much worse than
live like
I Friday you're gonna go out a dry eye
community
which they're being right wing fighter
like that should make the law and I
don't
I could elaborate light FL dust that a
lot of course if you're staring at a
computer screen to your telephone or
anything excess is gonna be back for you
I just don't care that much about dry
yes for stock
a girl with healthy eyes right now
walking into glad
wait till the day you operate developing
your phone goes right in your fair
there you'll hear up is there anything
we can do to fight this that could work
because we all do it we all believe
there is no doubt you know to me and I i
said it about the wake up being
I've been trying to shut down I try to
hide 9 o'clock now I've really been
trying I'm not always successful
to stop looking at Twitter so I'm doing
you know my little more I and II barely
open to Instagram every third day now I
every day I'm just tryna
too slowly do it but do you try to fight
it in a way
I discover encroaching but I might I
don't speak for
that so when she's going to like provide
the non stop crying yeah I think this is
I think this is really good information
and they're not even say Michael got
everybody apparently
23 now say iraq surveyed totally ravaged
do you yet what about you are you doing
anything to fight it
you admit it you freely admit it yeah II
more so the type person by
okay when I'm at home it's family time
let's put away our Father dinnertime
spyware called but not because I'm
scared dry i connect with her on people
I don't always been
you know doing it for the like I got 10
like get back to dinner time when you
talk to your family
that I use a dry he said he'd rather
the party such a benefit dry
I well I hope you guys enjoyed watching
this and that your eyes are fully
lubricated and we were and you had no
act it out
Gina but I thank you guys their twitter
is a right now below a court subscribe
alike
keep watching don't listen to that
segment that was not for you guys I
would prefer the general public with a
in a public service playing and we will
see you next week